gary vaynerchuk ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much although we got to
shake down to Jesus we expect so much
man
good afternoon thanks so much I know
it's everybody's looking to go and eat
dinner and things of that nature so I
really appreciate the people that have
stuck around morale that story is you
know I do like giving out $100 at a time
so if you make it through the keynote
feel free to come up here and ask for it
I'm gonna be rolling it out so I thought
I had an hour and now I have 15 minutes
so I've had a kind of adjust where I'm
going with this I think I'll just go
through this quite quickly and
ironically there's not a whole lot to
say so I could probably say it in 15
minutes which is this I think it's
really interesting I think it's really
super interesting that the last panel
which I thought was quite good talks
about growth hacking and mobile
marketing and content marketing and all
this stuff and it's really funny to
watch us you know human beings continue
to repackage the same [ __ ] over and over
right I mean we've literally
fundamentally for the last 200 years
have continued to repackage the same old
thing over growth hacking you know
growth hacking is like get customers
like let me just save everybody a lot of
time like growth hacking so so I think I
was sort of thinking about that and
listen um you know I have a micro
content production company right
like we continue to repackage the same
old thing and I will tell the people
who've lasted here long enough and I
know it's been a long day that you know
I really respect that and I want to
bring value to this conversation and
that's really what this is all about at
the end of the day no matter what you do
if you're a tremendous VC or an
entrepreneur or a brother or a sister or
a parent or anything you are in your
life and obviously in the context of
what a lot of us are here for which is
business you've got to bring value and
and nothing else really fundamentally
matters I want every single person to
look at the home screen of their phone
when they leave here today and look at
all the apps that take the home screen
of your phone this whole screen of your
telephone is probably one of the most
interesting looks into the psychology of
people right now I will probably get a
rested in the next 12 months because
every time I travel I'm looking over the
shoulder of 12 and 13 year old children
to get a good feel of what is on their
home screen because I'm desperately
interested in trying to understand what
their home screens look like different
than mine to understand the psychology
so if you ever read a beta beat article
that I got arrested I promise you it
wasn't I wasn't that pervy anyway if you
look at the home screen of your phone
there's really only three things no
matter if you're really [ __ ]
organized and put things into folders or
you just have the apps on there there's
really only three fundamental things on
your homescreen right
there's escapism which is games the
reason you know you know Angry Birds and
all these other things on your phone is
because our lives are complicated and
hard and we need escapism the reason
there are sports and music and all these
wonderful things that we actually are
quite passionate about is it actually
takes a few minutes out of our day a few
hours out of our day or week or year and
lets us not worry about all the crazy
[ __ ] that we actually have to worry
about and actually being a human being
and so escapism entertainment whatever
you want to look at it is quite
important and very very important number
two utility right if you look at your
phone a lot of you have your calendar
and your clear app to-do list utility
making your life better helping you get
to places do things of that nature how
do you make your life better and finally
social and that's the one I love to
really think a whole lot about because I
really do love people social is on your
homescreen social just took over gaming
and the thing that we spend the most
time on so you've got Facebook and
Pinterest and Tumblr Instagram and
Twitter and that's it
and at the end of the day what I think
about a lot is storytelling I asked my
wife that when I died to put storyteller
on my tombstone I've only done one thing
in my career right I I will tell this
crowd right now that for all the
accolades and all the fact that people
think I know what I'm doing I suck [ __ ]
at 99% of the things in the world the
one thing that I've got the one thing
that I got is I actually understood what
the consumer was going to do at scale a
little bit sooner than most people and
I'm not scared to go and market and
story tell and most importantly execute
in that market my whole life is
predicated
this I did not own a computer in my life
until I was 19 years old I launched
a.com for my family liquor store
business before I ever really was on the
internet my own self the only reason I
did that was because I truly believe
that you guys were going to do that I
truly believed that when I used to get
laughed at when I spoke at a conference
when I spoke at a conference that I got
laughed at when I said that all of you
would put a credit card into a computer
I knew that all of you were [ __ ]
stupid right
I mean that I really spoke at a
conference at everybody laughs and I was
on a panel and the person said this guy
think you're going to buy wine on the
Internet excuse me
this guy think you're going to buy wine
on the information superhighway remember
that's how he that's how what we used to
call it and and and and he asked the
audience and how many of you are ever
going to put your credit card into a
computer and nobody raised their hand
and I remember thinking at that moment
like holy [ __ ] this is amazing like
people don't really know what they're
going to do there are people in this
room right now that's swore to
themselves whether in their mind or to
other people that they would never be on
Facebook that they would never ever be
on Twitter but they are we're very good
at drawing lines in the sand what I'm
completely obsessed with and what I care
about is that I know that ad ad tech in
that second floor where all those
companies were presenting their products
that 98% of them were features that 98%
of the companies that were in the panels
today were features they're features
right now if they have a story telling
CEO or an operating CEO maybe they can
drive into some sort of success be
acquired by something else really even
run a nice sized business you know
selling your company isn't the only way
to go out making money each month and
having companies nice to but it's really
interesting right
being an SF being at a conference like
this being part of a panel of amazing
speakers like today we need to
fundamentally recognize that for all the
people in this room and in this space
and in this industry that are getting
caught up in amazing brain power that's
your view terrific thinking all those
things that this industry needs a cold
hard dose of old-school reality to have
success you know I think there's a lot
of people that
need to start realizing that the reason
there's a Series A crunch and things of
that nature is because [ __ ] like me
made a lot of money and started writing
twenty five thousand dollar checks to
everything and created this angel
investing thing and there's 98% of
people that have startups right now that
don't deserve to have startups because
they're not good enough and that 99% of
brands don't actually care about their
clients don't really care they care
about actually making quarterly numbers
because they're really playing a stock
market game not to actually bring value
to the end consumer game and so I think
we have a lot of interest misaligned in
2013 which very honestly for a guy like
me is an amazing opportunity and I think
is really interesting times I think it's
never been more interesting to innovate
and to and to be in business than right
now because the grounds are quite
fertile but the global misunderstanding
of what we're all supposed to be doing
has never been higher
because you have a lot of young people
that understand a lot of things but
don't understand how to actually
navigate and drive and run a business
you have a lot of people that bun you
like that if you don't know how to
navigate through which is the by the way
ironically even though I just said that
probably one of the best things that
ever happened to you
right because naivete because really
there's really always a king and yang
right the naivete often is what leads
you to the Holy Land but what's
interesting is a lot of people that do
know how to navigate try to spend too
much time on things that actually don't
matter let me talk to you about
something that I think the whole market
is thinking about quite a bit and I
wonder what happens in the practical
execution of it a huge buzz word in our
industry right now is Big Data right
Dana data is [ __ ] awesome I love data
data is tremendous but watching the
amount of data that's out there and the
amount of data that we're all sitting
through and cycling through and the
complete lack of execution against that
data because people are crippled by the
data is just one of the most interesting
things of all time I promise you one
thing everybody that's here we don't
need any more data there's plenty of
[ __ ] data do [ __ ] I promise it's true
we have plenty of data to do things
while people continue to build things on
top of that data and try to add value
and then try to sell that through and
it's just a very interesting time so I
don't know I've been sitting around
listening to everything today and
everything makes sense and it's all
fantastic but I don't think you know
maybe I'm a little tired later in a day
but I just want people to do [ __ ]
I think we're crippled by lack of
execution in this market more and more
and I was sitting back with marker and
somebody came up to me he's like oh I
started this interview series and all
these people are reaching out to me and
I've only done four videos and I look
them I said you know a funny thing
happens when you start doing [ __ ] and I
think that what we need to start
understanding is not only there's a
comma too that not only is it about
doing [ __ ]
but once and for all we need to start
looking ourselves in the mirror and
asking ourselves does the service we
provide do I as an employee do i as the
VC do I as an entrepreneur do I as a
journalist do I actually bring value to
the ecosystem because the funny thing is
as much as I've massaged it and as much
as I thought about it and I've built a
several you know 30 40 60 70 million
dollar businesses in my career so I've
had success and as much as I massaged it
over and over it comes down to a couple
little things do you bring value and do
you know how to articulate that value in
story let me explain the thing that I'm
most fascinated by right this second in
the world is this following thing that
Facebook is so bad at telling its story
that brands and people in the world
right now think that the sponsored story
product by Facebook is a ripoff brands
believe that they're getting capped on
their organic reach on Facebook so that
you have to buy more Facebook ads to
actually reach your audience
however facebook sponsor stories is the
only product in the world that I know
that works like this do you know that if
you want to spend money on a piece of
content on Facebook if you want to
sponsor a piece of content and that
piece of content is [ __ ] that Facebook
will not take your money let me say it
again Facebook will not take your money
you cannot spend the money that you want
against sponsoring a post because if
it's not getting enough engagement
Facebook will stop showing it and not
take your money do you think that there
is one TV network or one newspaper or
one banner [ __ ] ad platform that when
you deliver your banner ad to them and
they look at it like this is horseshit
let's give them back half their money do
you think that [ __ ] exists it doesn't
mean while Facebook's getting murdered
because they don't know how to story
tell and this is happening over and over
and I look at these things I'm like this
is the greatest greatest ad product that
has happened a long time that if a piece
of content is doing well you can amplify
it because you could actually react to
the data not do an upfront let's spend
this money and let's see what happens
they'll actually respond to reality of
the marketplace and pay against it and
meanwhile it's being looked upon
terribly because here's an interesting
scenario where a company brought
tremendous value but didn't know how to
story tell and that's why storytelling
and the theme of everything and
everything I ever think about matters
listen I'm going to tell you no probably
because there's not that many people
here I'll share my secret I get much
more credit than I deserve for my
accomplishments in my career and the
only reason that is is because I'm just
a much better storyteller than a lot of
other people that have done plenty of
things in their career that are greater
or better than me and I think that we
need to think about that I promise you
that the greatest book that I was ever
written and the best movie of all time
didn't open didn't sell because they
didn't know how to story tell the
quality of that content and so content
matters and content matters so much to
me and the reason that I'm super pumped
to watch my whole vaynermedia SF crew
when I look at them I said myself we're
doing smart work we're storytelling
native to the way the world is I know
that the world now lives that you guys
live in a world that looks like this
how should I just call my wife with my
good sorry anyway that that we live in a
world that we do this right and how do
you stop somebody in this new AVD stream
economy that we live in and tell a story
how do you live in a world now where we
are paying attention to 90 things how do
you stop them and tell a story and the
answer is by doing it natively dan from
share through was in a very important
guy and I hope he got his licks in in
that panel because panels are tough in
15 minutes with five bucket
what the [ __ ] were you thinking bonding
but but if you got his licks in holy
[ __ ] don't break your computer
I know it's good stuff up here but
[ __ ] calm down anyway how do you stop
somebody when we're in this world right
it was easy to do good commercials in
the 1970s he came home he had a long day
work you pop the beer you set your
[ __ ] ass on a couch and you like
couldn't the no DVR you [ __ ] [ __ ] no
remote control you know even if you
didn't want to watch this [ __ ] you're
like I'm not getting [ __ ] up right
and so you consumed and it was easy to
story tell because that's the way we did
and if you look back I'll leave you with
this tidbit because I got a minute I
would tell a lot of people in this room
to look back historically at what the
Leo Burnett company did in the 1960s the
Leo Burnett company was an ad agency
that did something quite smart they
understood the psychology to why you
watch television which was escapism
which was character based marketing and
you watch television for Gunsmoke you
watched television for I Dream of
Jeannie
so when commercial time came they gave
me more of what you wanted instead of
what they wanted they gave you the
Marlboro Man they gave you tony the
tiger they gave you the Keebler elves
they story told in the way that you
wanted it and so what I'm spending a lot
of my time these days on is I know that
you the world is spending more and more
time in your mobile devices and on
social networks and I have to figure out
and you have to figure out and every
brand has to figure out and every
startup has to figure out and every
human has to figure out how do I get my
story across in that world which oh by
the way is much harder happens much
faster
all of a sudden six seconds when we saw
vine come out we're like yeah we already
knew that videos under 10 seconds did
better on Facebook than anything over 10
seconds so when we saw six second video
we were up to the task as a company to
storytelling six seconds because much
like when I saw Twitter people do you
guys remember how people were freaking
the [ __ ] out on 140 characters like go
mean articles about Twitter in late 2006
and early 2007 that said we'll never
figure out how to communicate in 140
characters they have to extend this
eventually we figured it out I mean
they're a grown-ass men in this room
that have texted in the last 24 hours
things like oMG and lol we adjust we
completely as a society underestimate
the evolution of how human beings
communicate we used to write [ __ ] on
caves then we did [ __ ] smoke signals
and we evolved and I promise you that
what's happening right now is part of
that evolution and we will always figure
it out and it is not sad when you go out
to dinner and see couples looking at
their phone and not talking to each
other because they're talking to the
person they'd rather be talking to and
that's better than it used to be we will
always sell populate and do what we want
it is our job as marketers and
entrepreneurs and VCS and brands to
figure out how to get into that stream
in a non-disruptive way I think I think
we're living in very special times and I
hugely appreciate you giving me 15
minutes have a good day fifth question
yep so we're going to where over time
but first of all Wow what's always
inspiring are you talking Thank You fun
it was like in the back it's like you're
watching like the show newsroom and he's
like you know giving the edik to the
change of the media industry and so I
spend most of my days in boardrooms you
have been in a number of those
boardrooms we have the biggest challenge
you think are in those boardrooms that
everybody's full of [ __ ] that people
don't make that people know but it's
true right like let's really like well
especially since I man I [ __ ] love it
when it's like this so let's reflect
live let's talk about it for real right
the problem with boardrooms are people I
was so naive to corporate America I was
entrepot my whole life I grew my
family's business then I was into
startups corporate America somebody
makes a decision in a boardroom or some
of your businesses that is completely
predicated on their bonus not what's
best for the product or completely
predicated on how they can politically
grow within the organization or how to
make their boss look good bad or
indifferent so what ends up happening is
you sit in a boardroom where people
aren't aligned on what's right me my dad
bought every single day for nine years
building Wine Library every day I fought
with my dad I'm proud to sit here and
say that I cried a hundred times cried
but there's one thing I think back to
now that blows my mind which is that my
dad and I only ever gave a [ __ ] about
logo it was never about what my dad
wanted it was never about what I wanted
it was never about who made more money
it was nothing other than the [ __ ]
look wide life right that's not
happening at board rings corporate
America people give a [ __ ] about selling
more cereal or soda or [ __ ] anything
there's thinking about other things and
there's seven agendas I mean I have a
very tough time with what's going on
between agencies and brands I don't
think that our agendas are aligned like
you know I think agencies do a terrible
job back to my naivete to you guys like
I didn't run an agency I think the
reason we built a really big company
really fast as I didn't know the rules I
didn't know that like you should charge
for every hour that you sneeze right
like I didn't know this [ __ ] I just want
to do the best work I just wanted to do
what was right I just wanted to sell
[ __ ] go figure
fair enough
but you know at the same time so it's
real bond that no I looked at I stood
there with you I the challenge that I
faced more than anything is what I see
is so there's one set of people in the
boardroom no no I want you to say that
there's one set of people in the board
room which is senior leaders there is
another set of people in the boardroom
which are more junior marketers that
enter into a system that is actually
built on not necessarily making sure
that they live up to their potential so
what makes me nervous and you well then
let's talk about the school then yeah
ferret out like if you really want to
know I think this is one of the real
conspiracy yeah but I think they're just
cool too I think you know look one for
so many people have student loans raise
your hands yeah [ __ ] blows that's
enough worship or you know so we did we
did it we did a survey out of the top
100 business schools all of the
descriptions of classes only 1% of those
descriptions use the word digital in it
yes so let me tell you something about
business schools in America you're
looking at somebody right now who failed
who failed I always have the preface if
I tell all my friends I was a bad
student and I'm hanging out with all
these [ __ ] millionaires and geniuses
I think they think that I got these
right I'm like no [ __ ] I got [ __ ]
apps right so you're talking to somebody
up here right now who failed all his
classes who went to Mount Ida College
right because I got a postcard in the
mail second semester of my senior year
and brought in my guidance counselor and
she's like the bucket go and so all
right so meanwhile now I go and speak at
all these places right I go to Harvard
and the University of Chicago and
Michigan and all these places and I
always go and sit and listen to the
curriculum before I speak because what I
sniffed out was like holy shares a
visible abysmal they're talking about
[ __ ] that Isabella got three years ago
let alone now it's crazy and I actually
think we're failing most of the people
who are entering in as a result of that
but the other thing I think so the
challenge I think you face is which I
see you face sometimes directly is that
so many brand marketers are afraid to
actually take your guidance and pull the
trigger on the things that you're
suggesting
of course because nobody gets fired for
doing television or big-nose that was
the bigger problem that is not that they
don't get fired they become obsolete in
25 years and they sit and say stagnant
and exactly in place in their career so
what I get frustrated about is that
they're not told that the way to
actually grow is to do things different
by the way there's a ton of people who
look the same there's berry soup I think
I think I think the other thing is we
have to realize it's not an
all-or-nothing game the thing that is
blowing it away about corporate or these
organizations is that they don't have a
Navy SEALs unit right like the US
government is the biggest thing and we
have the biggest military and I always
use this equation right like we have a
big army television print you know we
have a big army scale right but to get
certain jobs done there's like 40 dudes
40 chicks right that make [ __ ] happen
the fact that these organizations have
not created allocation of dollars for
ninja units to go out and actually make
[ __ ] happen seems crazy to me because
it's a very small allocation of dollars
in the scheme of what they spend each
year and meanwhile I mean listen you
know this and if we're going to get into
this like you have your very junior
brand managers controlling the money not
senior leadership which is fascinating
to me right I think that's a good thing
I just think that we have anybody I'm to
certain characters there's good you know
like and then I sit in all these senior
meetings that are like well the brand
manners aren't doing their job like this
whole you're [ __ ] not giving them the
permission and the funny thing is in the
end of the day I'd especially judge
he does say that by the way when they're
and you're like what he really means is
that the appropriate terminology sorry
sir
anyway I you know we're running out of
time I just thought that it was
interesting and I also think so you
talked about the big date I walked by a
panel and said big data needs to be
small data and I was like really that's
kind of the but I thought it was
interesting about the repackaging so one
last question so what do you think is
again I'm talking from the brand
marketers sampler what kind of think is
the one if you could tell them to go do
one thing that would help open up their
perspective what would it be hawkman
there's so many um one thing one thing
one focus one thing that could open up
there the problem for me with that
answer is that answer that question and
I'm as many of you know I'm never sure
to give a quick answer is that I only
care about execution only trip about
execution so when I try to
reverse-engineer what a brand marketer
needs to do to actually then go and
execute it could be going to a
conference of being inspired it could be
going and working with a start-up for a
month to see how it actually is but the
reality is it's almost like you know if
I told them to do one thing it'd be to
go tell their bosses what they actually
feel because the horseshit is what's
really the problem the fact that that's
the community it's it's like
relationships it's you know people don't
communicate enough right like we just
don't communicate enough like there's
just too much horseshit there's too much
[ __ ] and then people are crippled to
go and execute and that's the real thing
that you see and the reason I think that
my company can execute is that I have
not been able to convince my team that
I'm not joking that I want to give them
15 minutes at a time and that they can
say anything it's been surprising to me
that they haven't taken me up on that
it's been surprising they're still
scared of me and that makes me realize
holy [ __ ] infrastructure like me right
like you see what I am right there's
still that intimidation based on layers
how do we create something that gets
actual authentic real dialog going on
because everybody is crippled by
[ __ ] rules and tons of tradition
that doesn't actually matter in a 2014
world and that's why Barnes and Noble
and borders go out of business that's
why in the consumer packaged goods
brands you guys are always trying to buy
Chobani and Red Bull and vitamin water
and you're unable to do it yourselves
because there's just too much horseshit
which makes you slow and everything is
predicated on speed speed is the game
and if you can't execute fast you can't
win because by the time you execute on
your promise the world [ __ ] moved on
you all right ladies and gentlemen give
a big round of applause to Gary
[Music]